- - Bonjour à vous trois.
IlIl y a une conférence de prese
auaujourd'hui pour faire le poit
susur la sixième vague. On a
dédépassé le cap des 2000
hohospitalisations et le réseau
hohospitalier est encore sous
prpression. À Québec, les partis
d'd'opposition demandent au
prpremier ministre de reprendree
leleadership. On ne l'a pas vu
dedepuis des semaines en
coconférence de presse sur la
COCOVID-19. Il a réagi aujourd'i
dadans les corridors de
l'l'Assemblée nationale.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - On suit ça de très proche.
PoPour l'instant, la santé
pupublique ne recommande pas,
onon n'a pas l'intention d'ajour
dedes mesures.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE
chcheffe du parti libéral
- - On a eu un premier ministre
omomniprésent dans la question
dede la pandémie avec la santé
pupublique, puis aujourd'hui,
onon assiste à complètement
l'l'inverse. Je pense qu'il y a
unun juste milieu. Jouer de
prprudence ce sera la bonne cho.
VIVINCENT MARISSAL porte-parole
QuQuébecec solidaire, Santé
- - La grande crainte, c'est
lele personnel soignant. Qui toe
enen ce moment au combat.
LLà, on s'en va vers l'été,
leles vacances.
- - On d disait qu'il fallait
prprendre des mesures dans touts
leles sphères de la société
etet aujourd'hui, on fait comme
sisi la pandémie était derrière
nonous.
- - Je vous lance la première
ququestion, Stéphanie. Est-ce qe
vovous estimez que le gouvernemt
LeLegault en fait assez dense
gegestion de la pandémie?
- - On a été rapide enlevé les
memesures sanitaires sont
nénécessairement évalués quel
seserait l'impact du retrait de
chchacune d'entre elles. On se
reretrouve maintenant dans une
sisituation où on a une sixième
vavague. Est-ce qu'on doit
reremettre des mesures? Le réseu
n'n'est pas au point de rupture.
OnOn l'espère qu'il y aura un
plplateau. Est-ce que François
LeLegault doit s'impliquait
dadavantage? Je pense que ce n't
papas anodin s'il ne participe
plplus aux conférences de press.
IlIls ont dissocié ça de la Sané
pupublique, parce qu'on est en
cacampagne électorale avec les
élélections dans Marie-Victorin
cecette semaine et sa marque le
cocoup d'envoi de la campagne pr
leles élections. La CAQ n'a pas
enenvie de rester englué dans ls
ququestions qui ne sont pas
nénécessairement gagnantes poura
CACAQ.
- - C'est un sujet qui divise
bebeaucoup dans la population, s
didirectives de la Santé publiq,
sisi on doit remettre davantage
dadans les écoles notamment.
EÉmilie, est-ce que c'est une
bobonne chose de remettre la
reresponsabilité de la gestion e
lala pandémie aux citoyens?
- - C'est compliqué et ça pose s
ququestions dans les provincesùu
ilil y a moins de mesures
sasanitaires qu'au Québec. En
mamatériau, pas de masse n'est
plplus obligatoire et ça suscite
bebeaucoup de questionnements.
CeCes aucunes des questions que
j'j'ai dans ce contexte pour le
gogouvernement Legault, c'est la
ququestion du délestage et des
gegens sur les listes d'attente.
QuQu'on nous rassure en disant e
leles hôpitaux ne sont pas à
plpleine capacité, est-ce que ça
veveut dire que lorsque les lits
d'd'hôpitaux sont de plus en pls
ococcupés par des patients de
COCOVID-19, ça ralentit le
rarattrapage à faire sur les ges
enen attente des fois depuis pls
d'd'un an pour des chirurgies nn
ururgentes. C'était un débat qun
avavait lors de la cinquième vae
etet on dirait que cette questin
esest complètement évacuée de la
fafaçon dont calculent les lits
d'd'hôpitaux dont on a besoin.
- - Christian, les parties ont
tetellement demandé d'avoir des
popoints de presse indépendant n
dedessous du gouvernement, est-e
ququ'on est allé un peu trop lon
àà l'autre explicitement laissat
prpresque tous les terrains au
DoDocteur Boileau?
- - Le gouvernement et M. Legaut
enen particulier, on sent qu'ils
nene veulent pas dramatiser une
sisituation qui est sérieuse. Je
reregrette qu'on n'utilise
l'l'expression sixième vague,
c'c'est inutilement anxiogène et
çaça rappelle les premières vags
ququi étaient autres choses,
bebeaucoup plus dramatique. Au
QuQuébec, on porte encore le
mamasque. Ce qui semble manquer,
c'c'est de rappeler aux gens, ax
popopulations qui ne sont pas
ââgées l'importance de la
trtroisième dose. Ça semble être
lala lacune. Je trouve que la
memessage n'est pas assez envoy.
LaLa troisième dose est très
fofortement recommandée. On ne
prprévoit pas revenir avec des
cocontraintes sanitaires. Ces
memesures ont fait mal à la
popopulation. Je trouve qu'au
QuQuébec, on n'y est allé un peu
fofort. Le danger c'est que
mamaintenant on relâche.
J'J'aimerais que le gouvernement
fafasse une campagne de publicié
pourur dire que ce sont les gens
ququi sont responsables et d'y
alaller pour la troisième dose.l
nene faut pas tout relâcher.
- - La troisième dose est beaucp
momoins populaire que les deux
prpremières doses.
OnOn est à l'aube du long week-d
dede Pâques ils y en a qui ont s
rarassemblements familiaux de
prprévu. Stéphanie, est-ce qu'ee
apappelle à la présidence, ça
susuffit aussi il y a des
didirectives plus claires qui
seseraient nécessaires à votre
avavis?
- - Un appel à la prudence est
totoujours utile. Mais je
rerenchéris sur ce que dit
ChChristian. Je pense qu'il y a
bebeaucoup de gens qui ne se sot
papas faits vacciner parce que e
soson de cloche n'étaiait pas c.
IlIl y a des spécialistes qui
didisaient encore il n'y a pas
trtrès longtemps que s'il y avat
eueu des gens qu'il avait eus, l
n'n'y avait pas d'empressement.
MMême que ça pouvait être utile
d'd'attendre. Aujourd'hui, on ae
cocomité consultatif canadien qi
didit : allez-y, c'est le temps
était utile. Peut-être qu'il
vavaudrait bien qu'il y a une
cacampagne qui se reremette pour
enencourager les gens à aller
prprendre leur troisième dose.
C'C'est un outil qui est très
efefficace.
- - C'est ce qu'éviter les grans
rarassemblements, porter le
mamasque, je pense que c'est des
chchoses qui vont sous le sens n
cece moment. Il y a moins
d'd'abondance de grands
rarassemblements durant le temps
dede Pâques que durant les fêtes
dede fin d'année. Ceci dit, je e
sasais pas s'il y a encore des
gegens Québec qui ne connaissent
pepersonne qui a la COVID
prprésentement, mais le fait est
ququ'il y a tellement de gens ce
momoment qui la COVID 19 que çaa
unun impact sur les
rarassemblements.
- - Espérant que le beau temps a
rerevenir bientôt. Il y a aussi
dedes problèmes de grippe, c'est
papas juste la COVID. Il faut
évéviter l'approche anxiogène.Ça
fafait deux ans qu'on était dans
unune approche anxiogène et je
pepense qu'il faut dépasser ça.
- - Je voulais vous parler du
trtroisième lien entre Québec et
LéLévy. Un projet très cher au
gogouvernement de la CAQ. Le
prprojet va être plus modeste ac
dedeux tunnels plutôt qu'un, mos
dede voix, moins cher, sous les7
mimilliards. Le projet a été
prprésenté au maire de Québec et
dede Lévy.
GIGILLES LEHOUILLIER,
mamaire de Lévis
- - J'ai aimé ce que j'ai vu.
C'C'est un magnifique projet
etet c'est un projet d'avenir.
C'C'est un projet d'avenir
popour le transport en commun.
OnOn va éliminer une fois
popour toutes le fameux fer
àà cheval entre les deux rives.
BRBRUNO MARCHAND, maire de Québc
- - Nous, on demeure toujours
avavec les mêmes questions :
ququ'est-ce qu'on fait
popour l'étalement urbain?
CoComment on en fait un projet
ququi est environnemental,
ququi est intéressant?
CoComment on en fait un projet i
n'n'ajoutera pas à la circulatin
auautomobile à Québec?
CoComment on fait pour avoir
unune évaluation avec des faits
ququi vont nous démontrer
ququ'on est capable de rendre ça
inintéressant? Les mêmes questis
dedemeurent. Le gouvernement
coconnaît nos questions,
coconnaît nos conditions
etet il va travailler avec ça.
- - Vous vous attendez qu'elle
acaccueille pour ce projet plus
momodeste?
- - Ça va dépendre à quel pointn
a a des détails dans ce qu'on va
nonous présenter, parce que c'et
bibien de dire qu'il va y avoire
tutunnel au lieu d'un seul. A
prpriori, c'est une bonne chose
paparce que sur le plan techniq,
avavoir un seul tunnel extrêmemt
lalarge, ça aurait pris un
tutunnelier plus gros que ce qun
n'n'a jamais utilisé partout à
trtravers le monde. Ça paraissat
exextrêmement périlleux. Si on
pepeut arriver avec une solution
ququi est sur le plan techniquen
pepeu plus réaliste, tout le moe
vava s'en réjouir. Mais ça ne
rrègle pas tout. Le fleuve est
crcru à cet endroit-là, il y aua
dodonc une pente importante qui
fafait en sorte que pour les
popoids-lourds, la vitesse serat
trtrès réduite. Ça ne serait pas
popossible pour la circulation s
mamarchandises dangereuses. Au-
dedelà des aspects techniques
ququ'on essaie de résoudre, je
pepense que la question la plus
imimportant dans tout ça, c'est:
esest-ce qu'on a besoin de trois
amamis? Si la réponse qu'il n'y
auaura pas d'augmentation de la
popopulation active sur la rive
susud au cours des 20 prochaines
anannées, où est la justificati?
C'C'est pour réduire le fefer à
chcheval, etc. Mais c'est quand
mmême beaucoup d'argent. On
paparlait jusqu'à 10 milliards
popour la première version, este
quque ce sera moins? Peut-être.
MaMais c'est énormément d'argent
ilil y aurait peut-être mieux à
fafaire pour réduire des problès
dede congestion dans la région e
QuQuébec.
- - Il y a encore des gens
coconvaincre sur le bien-fondé e
cece projet-là. Émilie, on
enentendait le maire de Québec,
crcraignait l'étalement urbain.
- - Non seulement ces conditions
sosont essentielles à rencontre,
mamais c'est en les mettant sura
tatable, on voit qu'elles sont
inincompatibles avec l'idée même
d'd'un troisième lien, selon mo.
JeJe ne vois pas comment on peut
fafaire un troisième lien sans
fafavoriser de facto l'étalement
ururbain. Je ne connais pas de
pepetit village de communauté à
QuQuébec qui ont été épargné par
l'l'étalement urbain lorsque
l'l'autoroute a été élargie ou t
rerendue jusqu'à. Ça m'a fait
sosourire qu'on n'en parle
dédésormais comme projet modest.
OnOn est passé d'une évaluatione
1010 milliards à 7 milliards et
c'c'est la magie de la psycholoe
d'd'avoir proposé d'abord un
prprojet tellement cher et puisn
dedescend à 7 milliliards et ona
l'l'impression que c'est un prot
ababordable alors que cette
mimilliard de dollars, ça resten
prprojet pharaonique. Si on avat
prproposé d'emblée un projet cee
mimilliard de dollars, personne
n'n'aurait qualifié ça de projet
momodeste. Avec cette milliard e
dodollars ce qu'on peut faire en
édéducation, dans le réseau des
CPCPE, en santé des personnes
ââgées, c'est absolument
gigigantesque. Je pense que c'et
inintéressant que la CAQ essaiee
prprésenter un projet comme ça
cocomme projet modeste, ces
fafascinants niveaux de la
cocommunication politique.
- - On entendait aussi la réactn
dudu 20 maires de Lévis, qui
sesemblait plus reculer le maire
dede Québec.
- - Ces projets sont beaucoup tp
popolitisés et idéologiques. Je
trtrouve que la région de Québec
dedevrait avoir le tramway et le
trtroisième lien. J'espère que
BrBruno Marchand va avoir un peu
dede vision et va collaborer avc
lele gouvernement du Québec pour
quque le troisième lien se
réréalise. Je crois qu'on a les
momoyens de se payer les deux.
MaMais j'ai un point de vue
pepersonnel là-dedans, ce qui ne
dédérangera pas Québec, c'est un
vévélo la qualité de vie est
exexceptionnelle, une ville
mamagnifique, romantique et
clclasse. C'est une des plus
bebelles villes du monde, Québe.
J'J'ai peur qu'on construise des
hohorreurs. C'est ça, ma
prpréoccupation. Je me souviensu
cocomplexe j'ai eu, de l'hôtel e
coconcorde, de l'auberge du
gogouverneur, de ce qu'on a fait
avavec le boulevard René Lévesq.
PePersonne ne parle de ça. Il ft
leles deux, mais ses
ininfrastructures vont défigurer
unune des plus belles villes du
momonde il serait peut-être des
gegens qui s'intéressent à
l'l'esthétisme, c'est un capital
lala beauté de Québec.
- - On aura les détails demain n
coconférence de presse. En
teterminant, un mot sur l'Ukrai.
JoJoe Biden a qualifié les actes
dede la Russie de génocide.
EmEmmanuel Macron refuse
d'd'utiliser ce terme. La questn
ététait posée à Justin Trudeau,
ququi dit qu'on peut de plus en
plplus parler de génocide. On et
unun peu entre deux.
- - On va voir la réponse quandl
y y aura des enquêteurs qui vont
alaller sur le terrain pour
rérécolter des preuves. C'est la
CoCour pénale internationale qui
pepeut vraiment dresser la
frfrontière entre ce qui est un
crcrime de guerre, ce qui est un
gégénocide. Quant au pas de
gégénocide, on sait que poutinee
veveut pas reconnaître l'identié
dedes ukrainiens. C'est quand me
unun signe qu'il y a des risques
ququ'on s'approche de ça. Mais
popour l'instant, comment tracer
lala ligne? Ça prend des
enenquêteurs sur le terrain.
- - Ce qui se passe, c'est que
dedepuis 2005 l'adoption de la
popolitique de la responsabilité
dede protéger, utiliser des mots
cocomme génocide et crimes de
guguerre, s'implique qu'il faut
fafaire quelque chose. Ce n'est
papas nécessairement... c'est ue
ququestion de ce que ça implique
d'd'en faire plus en Ukraine.
UtUtilise pas le mot génocide,
ququ'est-ce que ça implique note
ababsence d'intervenir dans
d'd'autrtres pays où il y a tout
auautant des crimes de guerre et
dedes crimes contre l'humanité.
C'C'est une situation.